welcome back to new rockstars loki is
weeks away and we are now getting to
know the tva's official mascot named
miss minutes miss minutes
seriously i just so keep this thing
i don't know what this is but i like it
it's a cute little design it's fun
hey we're using the wrong wtf because
now we're going into loki baby we gotta
come up with a new wtf
okay and we'll test it out but for now
i'm thinking it's going to be in honor
of our man mobius and mobius
wow
[Laughter]
wow i like it
you can say it like that every time wow
the [ __ ] is going on here
if we start we might update it as we go
we'll we'll see we eventually
went from what the falcon to what the
[ __ ] so
[Laughter]
hey this is inside marvel i'm eric boss
i'm here with mt
how you doing mtv you excited for loki
oh hell yeah dude like loki got them
wanda vision mystery vibes that we all
love and crave so you know that i'm
excited for loki you already know
yeah oh this show is going to be great
i'm so excited uh the level of detail
they're going into the sense of humor
the whole aesthetic the concept dude
i've been
begging for the tva for years so like
the fact that we're actually getting it
amazing i literally screamed when i saw
the tva on loki's shirt and the teaser
oh well we want to announce that with
loki moving to wednesdays
starting june 9th our inside marvel
after shows will also move from fridays
to wednesdays
and our episode easter egg breakdowns
will come out as soon as possible the
following day most likely on thursdays
but until june 9th mt and i are going to
be with you here on fridays
talking about all the big stuff to look
forward to in marvel phase 4 including
loki today we're going to do a deep dive
into the tva
its whole history and how it could be
restructuring the marvel multiverse as
we know it
and of course we're going to ask where
all of miss minutes bodies are buried
[Laughter]
scattered across time of course i mean
she wouldn't be that sloppy
we should be asked when they're buried
right yeah
that's the best serial killer is time
travel and what
you know miss minutes probably uh didn't
kennedy honestly
i saw her there i saw that that orange
here in the bushes from the grassy knoll
we begin over at newrockstarsmerch.com
we've got an amazing selection of
t-shirts hoodies even a new rockstars
onesie for the youngest nerd in your
life
so head on over to newrockstarsmerch.com
to see all of our great merch options
uh including this hi i'm eric voss shirt
it's the only shirt i wear right now it
smells terrible
but if you buy it new you'll get a nice
smelling one uh and we have a great loki
design in the works
we can't wait for you guys to see it but
mt
what is our very first wow
well eric the first wow the [ __ ] of the
day
is wow the f is miss minutes secret eric
i mean
she's a little cute little mysterious
mascot of the tva what's her deal yeah
what is her deal well miss minutes of
course the name of the tva mascot who is
so important empty that she even gets
top billing in this latest loki poster
have you seen this
amazing oh man it looks nice i like it
yeah
so yes for our audio listeners she is an
animated character she's orange
she's a clock she wears white gloves and
shoes and she probably wants to devour
your soul
um now miss minutes actually appeared
back in the april trailer on
a poster in the background of the tva
check-in room
and it looked like she was curb stomping
another clock as she warns
behave or you'll get your clock cleaned
oh [ __ ] uh she also appears as kind of a
caged cuckoo bird
in an animated clock on all these
monitors labeled a12
a10 and so on but actually if you
remember back to our very first
trailer in december miss minutes also
sneakily appeared as a button on the tva
elevator and actually if you go back and
listen to that moment in the trailer
as the camera moved down upon that
button you hear a devilish little piano
trill
and now we know from a merch leak that
her name is miss minutes and
in the merch she steps out of the
circular portal saying
woo doggy doggy
and then creepily another motto at the
bottom that says for
all time always it seems simple enough
to say miss minutes is just simply the
tva mascot kind of like smokey the bear
or uncle sam or scruff mcgruff
you know kind of seems like something
part of that 70s aesthetic where they
cope with these goofy little mascots
that
keeps you working keeps you on time but
the fact that she's in the elevator
she's selectable as like either a
destination or a kind of function
it suggests that more could be going on
with her
so empty go with me on this here's my
theory okay let's go
i think she's the kind of attack dog
like the tva's
torturer so you push this button
and your detainee gets trapped in an
animated torture dungeon
where miss minutes beats the [ __ ] of
them
it just cleans your clock for hours for
days
i hope to god yeah that is actually what
happens
it's like an animated hellscape
hellscape and you're trapped in there
for an unlimited amount of time for all
time
always right it's kind of like in black
mirror the
the white christmas episode with jon
hamm it's just they torture these people
in these mine prisons and
oh my god on the outside and you're in
there forever and ever and ever
and it's kind of like your time in hell
was to everyone else
missed minutes oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and think about an mc we know
this is the worst possible torture for
loki because dr
strange made him fall endlessly for 30
minutes and thor ragnarok he didn't know
if he was ever going to be
unbanished from that and then
at several points in the low-key footage
that we've seen you see loki
dropping out from just a from a hatch
and he looks super rattled and freaked
out like how long
because he just got [ __ ] up by miss
minutes that's why exactly
so i'm just thinking this series is
being written by rick and morty writer
mike waldron and that's exactly the kind
of dark absurdism you would see
in that kind of universe like characters
like mr me seeks like
existence is pain you know i mean if you
get a writer like that
you gotta put it stuff like that like
it's your responsibility
yeah so i i think this is kind of like
the the dark side of the tva because the
tva seems like super bureaucratic very
douglas adams like you're just going
through the dmv and that's how they
represent the cosmos to you
but uh but i think they have a dark side
and i think this clock is going to be a
kind of like
uh the bane of loki's existence in the
tva
that would be so great i hope so just
like a little
cute little torturer mascot like that'd
be such a fun little twist
and you know as an animated character
with a catchphrase like woo
doggy i think we could probably expect a
well-known voice actor to voice his
character
i mean do you have any thoughts of who
this could be empty um
i mean i have an idea where you may be
going with this are we talking justin
roiland
oh that would be fun
i would say yeah justin really someone
from the rick and morty universe you
know
could be really fun uh like i'm trying
to think sarah
chalky or tara strong we interviewed her
for explained like this kind of seems
like a character she's like
oh man you interviewed tara strong i'm
so jealous she's so great
so nice she's a goddess of voice acting
oh my god she would be great for miss
minutes
yeah uh i mean i would love for like
event nicole brown to voice his
character
i think that'd be so fun just to hear
her like being
lucky she would be great actually that'd
be funny though
i would love that yeah i'm just
wondering is there
any other you know theory there with
this uh
with this character is this why are they
on the poster is what i'm wondering
like is it just a joke that they're on
the poster i mean what what you
described in that like animated world
that you uh you wish is gonna happen um
it sort of reminds me like limbo
like the the limbo world so like they
could just take the void of limbo and be
like all right
we're just gonna put a little animated
torture world where we're just gonna
shove loki in
if he misbehaves or anyone that that
crosses us and uh that'd be great
i would love that yeah like i'm
wondering if like uh
so with the tva we have their founders
the time keepers right who are they
they kind of founded it they're they
were originally in the comics created by
he who remains as a way to kind of like
keep the time stream in check in a way
um but like they we don't know if
they're gonna appear as characters they
may have just been these
pseudo ancient figures who helped create
the tva and they kind of
worship on you know put on these
pedestals but like
that legacy may have been kept on
through some kind of like automated
program and that could be what miss
minutes is all about
but they don't fully understand it
almost like the cree supreme
intelligence it's just kind of like
technology beyond their understanding
but it's just like represented in a
simple form
so like when miss minutes gets too upset
they know something's wrong and then
she's like miss minutes won't come out
of her cuckoo
clock cage so we have to get things
right so miss minutes
we'll be our friend again that is a
really fun way of doing i like that
it's just like hey we're miss mitch is
sort of like the will of the original
time keepers in a way
is that if that's what you're going for
that's yeah i think it's like in the way
that bureaucracies
like at dmv sometimes they'll just have
like these stupid little posters on
there like remember to always punch out
when you go take a break
like they don't really even think about
it it's just this kind of
goofy dumb happy doggy
character who's actually like terrifying
and deadly if you cross her
[Laughter]
i like that i really do but i actually
in regards to the time keepers i think
they could actually be alive
i think they're just probably like high
like the highest level of the tva
it's like they're they're bosses and
it's like a wizard of oz like the the
man behind the curtain
yeah and like they have these um you
know statues of them
up just because like their egos it's
like we control time like of course like
we're gonna have big-ass statues and
like
we're they're we're at the top of the
elevator probably um so like
you know i i yeah i get that you know
what i want
is one of them to be kang the conqueror
like i want yes that
original sin of them that they're just
trying to never talk about is that one
of them went rogue
i did like the point that you brought up
in a past video because their helmets or
whatever is on their heads looks
very similar to kang's appearance so i
was like hey that's a really good link
eric i like that yeah well the fact that
there's three of them
like uh i can't help but think of
something like
minority report you know you had the
three three cogs and then one was
different from the others
like just that idea of the holy trinity
in a way like
uh these three figures and that was
based on a philip k
dick's short story which is also kind of
like inspiring this kind of world right
like
the idea of playing with sci-fi and time
and all that crap
like i could imagine that being kind of
an influence you know
where they can kind of see forward in
time and they just know things that
other people don't they're almost these
godly figures
uh but like they only work when all
three of them are together so if one of
them broke away
the other two were just kind of left you
know useless
yeah and so that's what did away with
the
power of the timekeepers so in order to
get past that they had to invent this
bureaucracy that could keep the time
stream in check
because their divine powers no longer
had the ability to
overrule it as gods oh
interesting i wonder if in that scenario
there is an
ability for upward movement like we're
looking for
a third time keeper so mobius
if you like play your cards right slayer
or one of these other figures because
that's how
that is kind of the promise of all
bureaucracies right it's like there's
it's a meritocracy you can get promoted
to be the director of it at some point
yeah
and like mobius seems like he has a
secret thing going on like he has secret
motivations
so like it could be upward momentum in
that scenario i do like that that's
right
yeah all right i'm excited to get more
information about the show
um like every trailer can't wait to look
more at and we'll be talking about loki
a lot
uh between now and june 9th but before
we continue with this episode we do have
more thoughts about loki of course
we want to thank some friends who helped
us make it so uh thank you to upstart
for sponsoring this episode if you dread
looking at your credit card statement
every month upstart can help lift that
weight off your shoulders
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple
fixed monthly payment unlike other
lenders upstart looks at more than just
your credit score like your income your
employment history
this means they can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners with a five minute
online rate check
you can see your rate up front with
loans between one thousand fifty
thousand dollars
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
marvel that's upstart.com marvel don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to upstart.com marvel we also want to
thank stamps.com for sponsoring this
episode are you still going to the post
office and paying full price for postage
well thanks to stamps.com you don't have
to anymore stamps.com brings the
services of the u.s postal service and
ups right to your computer here at new
rockstars we use stamps.com and it makes
off-screen producer zach's life way
easier when he's to ship
something to somebody working remotely
over one million businesses
choose stamps.com for their mailing and
shipping use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pick up or drop it off with stamps.com
you get discounts
up to 40 off post office rates and up to
off ups shipping rates so stop wasting
time going to the post office and go to
stamps.com instead there's no risk and
with our promo code
one division you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in one division that's
stamps.com promo code
onedivisionstamps.com never go to the
post office again
inside marvel is also sponsored by
better help lots of us have gone through
periods where something was interfering
with our happiness or preventing us from
achieving our goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating with them in
under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done
securely online it's available worldwide
and includes a broad range of expertise
that may not be available in your area
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you do
with traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today
join the over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional and they have a special
offer for our audience get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
marvel
that's better h-e-l-p dot com slash
marvel for 10 off your first month all
right mt
let's dive back into loki all right wow
the [ __ ]
is the big bad of this show
that is a good question because we don't
really have a clear idea of like who
that
is um i think that the big bad of the
show could potentially be
an alternate loki like a different uh
loki either from like a different
timeline or just a different
uh version of loki like in terms of like
the resurrection the asgardian
resurrections
there are rumors that richard e grant is
in the loki's show and i have this weird
feeling that he could be playing
king loki um from the comics which is
not really based on anything that's just
a hunch of mine but like it'd be really
cool to see
uh tom hiddleston face off against grant
in the show as a different version of
himself
because loki is pretty much his own
biggest enemy let's be real um
so it would be a cool little parallel
there that's a good point and empty in
the poster we see
both tom hiddleston in like his tva
attire but then underneath them there's
another loki
so there's like already we're seeing
like two versions of loki and everyone
else is just one character
maybe this is like a version of uh
remember the sony posters for spiderman
homecoming and there was like three
different versions of iron man on it yes
like how much type robert jr do we need
in the poster
exactly loki's a big enough ego to where
i kind of get why he's like also get me
in this concert
get one of me like this shot
but yeah i think we are going to look at
alternate loki's battling each other and
loki
being his own greatest enemy i think
makes a lot of logical sense for this
show
what do you think man who do you think
the like do you think it's going to be
loki or
well let's make uh well i think that is
like our safe theory right
we'll we'll have our safe theories which
this is what we think
most likely this is going to be but
we're going to draw a line here and have
our
reach theory okay so this is a reach
theory kind of like this is our our
princeton
or if you're in canada you're mcgill you
know like
you're not going to get into mcgill
it's the background but you got to reach
you know uh
so uh obviously we're all right
i can only speak for myself kang gang
i'm kang yang 100
i want kang the conqueror to be in the
show i think there's enough evidence
pointing to kang with justice wren
slayer being in the show
she is king's like squeeze in the comics
uh
i don't know if one of those time
keepers will be king for sure but it's
kind of like if the tva is in this
it makes sense for kang to also be part
of this you know oh yeah
kang is one of the biggest messer-uppers
of time ever
so like you know he has to play some
type of factor especially since he's
coming up
in ant-man and the wasp so yeah it would
be one time mania
the quantum media which is like my most
anticipated marvel movie
to date like right now it's gonna be so
much fun
i love it title's so weird it's so wacky
peyton reed always does a great job and
like
so good yeah but yeah kang being the
main villain in this show
would make sense i don't think that's
too far overreach considering the
factors that we have
but it is not as likely as an alternate
loki but it is still a fun
reach to to consider because we have
everything
we we have to do yeah hey and in the
trailers the
apparent villain is this hooded figure
that sofia di martino's character and we
think that it's just
you know another alternate loki that's
your lady loki that could be the villain
he's chasing yeah so
it's very likely considering like that
that shot in the trailer of um
them to you on that purple planet that
purple hued planet
sitting next to each other like there's
like a weird reflective
um cinematography there in that shot so
it sort of looks like
yeah this is like a loki talking to
another loki we're forgetting someone
though
remember that first trailer came out in
december and there was a stained glass
picture
of one very amazing demonic figure
who could it be could we still be on the
mephisto train here
hey man i hey if it wasn't for that
glass panel i did that little
what do you call it stained glass window
i would be like
maybe not mephisto but that's that's a
demon in that in that
window i mean you could argue we've
gotten more clues from afisto for loki
than we did for one division
yeah yeah like straight up like he's in
a church
and the churches have a thing against
demons
on a stained glass window i mean if one
division gave us that it'd be like
mephisto confirmed thumbnail you know
but you have to
also understand that like the tva exists
outside of time and space and so
does mephisto in his own little
dimensions so it's not
uncommon i mean so it wouldn't be
outside of you know the realm of
possibilities for these two for mobius
and mephisto
to potentially interact in some way
we'll keep our eye on this uh what's our
next uh
wow well i'm glad you asked eric because
a third while the [ __ ] of the day is
while the
are some other real world urban legends
loki
might tie into in addition to d.b cooper
levious
and pompeii yeah yeah you know when they
i think a second season the show's
already
greenlit right and i think the reason
why is
like the episodic structure of the show
is like
we're gonna explore all these different
historical mysteries and then show how
loki was behind it
so if you are pitching a whole series
with multiple seasons yeah you could
probably come up with several dozen of
those that could be like oh loki just
quantum leaped there and that's why it's
so weird we never had an answer to it
but like we did a big question episode
on this
and there are some mysteries that are
just maybe a little too dark things like
the jfk assassination zodiac jack the
ripper
you know like i don't want loki to have
been zodiac oh that's
terrible there's no redemption from that
yeah uh so but maybe some of the
the more cryptic less like murderous
ones like uh the mystery of
amelia earhart oh my god yes that would
hurt
that was so great one of my favorite
comic series this isn't even marvel it's
a
ivar time walker from valiant comics and
they go into the
the mystery of amelia earhart using time
travel so i would love to promote you to
explain that in some way like loki was
behind it or like
loki yeah what if what if that
mysterious lady that we think is another
version of loki
is amelia
hold on that would be awesome that would
be freaking
awesome um i like the idea of how in the
trailers we see him going back to pompei
the 7980 like going to different
historical time periods you know db
coopers in the 70s
like what if we went back to the lost
colony of roanoke you know
like in early colonial times
we find out what really happened and
loki was just like um go over to that
island over there right in the in the
tree
and now i get my own island oh my god
dude
there's so many things that they can do
and like i i'm like i'm a huge like
sci-fi time travel guy because like you
know i'm a huge doctor who nerd and like
you're
bigger than time travel than me so like
you already know the deal
but like stuff like this like going into
urban legends and like
tying it into like a fictional lore it's
it's
amazing i love that this kind of stuff
well there was one
uh like i i can't remember what year it
was but there was this mysterious signal
from space
and it was just like whoa it came out of
nowhere they got this
huge hit blast of frequency and
uh you know researchers have been trying
to figure out what it means the story of
contact was actually based on this
um but they called this the big
wow the big one the big wow is what it's
referred to
so if they could get owen wilson to say
wow just like i'm saying like they call
it the big wow like oh that'd be perfect
that would be so great if it was
actually a wow from owen wilson oh
amazing amazing say it once please
you have to be self-aware listen kevin
feige and the team
behind loki if that's not already in the
show you still have time to put it in
come on there's still time there's still
time just do an adr just get the people
who edited falcon winter soldier in
there and they were like we'll come up
with a whole new storyline
right and like do you know how many wows
owen wilson has said in his lifetime you
could just choose one he doesn't even
have to come in
i just had an idea we need to get loki
to explain what the [ __ ]
happened with donia madani oh my god
soldier
he actually gave her some weird illness
oh my gosh guardian stds are brutal
donya and loki used to be a thing for
some reason
i'm shipping those too oh my god
well we have a couple more questions but
we have one more person we want to thank
thank you to helix for sponsoring this
episode whether you're bunking up in
wakanda or wisconsin
you want to be sleeping on a mattress
designed to fit you and your body well
helix sleep has a quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
i took the quiz and i got matched with
the dusk lux helix mattress because i
wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support
that sleeps cool and i sleep great on
that helix mattress
the mattress comes right to your drawers
shipped for free you never need to go to
a mattress store again
they were awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq in
wired magazine
all you got to do is go to
helixsleep.com inside marvel
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
helix is offering up to two hundred
dollars off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our audience at helix
sleep dot com slash inside marvel that's
helix sleep dot com slash inside marvel
for up to two hundred dollars off into
free pillows
the next wow of the video is what new
logic will loki give the marvel
multiverse and time travel in the mcu
yeah okay so we talked about this
in a big question too i it's it seems
like they're going to go more in the
direction that end game took us in
and kind of say that there is a
multiverse right where there's alternate
timelines and if you take
an infinity stone out of its timeline
and don't replace it to its sequence of
events in history
then you kind of create a new timeline
of events in history
and that's how we get like you know the
time stream split into all these
different
histories right um but
it's also not clear if we're gonna do
one of those timelines where it's like
this always happened you know like it's
a predestined loop for you to go back
and set things the way they are in the
past
hmm yeah i don't really know what their
what type of
time travel rules really apply in the
mcu ever since
end game because i'm just like even when
hulk was trying to explain time travel
i'm like
did you really explain it though did
anyone really explain it
because i feel lost oh yeah and uh
not until the ancient one came in there
did we kind of get some clarity on
what exactly they were talking about
yeah um
but like i guess my question beyond this
is is loki going to be
kind of like a ten commandments rule
moment where we get
going forward these are the rules
they're set in stone uh or is it going
to
do be a not that just unties itself by
the end
and then you know realistically we don't
really
address it that much in future mcu
titles other than ones that specifically
want to
i think that loki will um lay down the
law of
time um in the show and in this like
yeah be like the introduction of like
here's what we're doing
with time travel here's how it's going
to go into the multiverse i don't know
exactly how they're going to do it but
like
you know with with having little mascots
like miss minutes like it
she reminds me of uh the pit boy from
fallout it's just like hey i'm gonna
explain these concepts to you and like
here's how time travel works
and like we're like the dna strand in
jurassic park
yeah it's i know dna so it's like
it's i feel like miss minutes was there
to help explain those hard concepts to
the audience
in a fun little uh way that's sort of
retro so
you know they i think some type of law
will be like set up
for future mcu installments um that deal
with with time travel and the multiverse
i feel like it's gonna tie more into
um obviously ant-man and the wasp um
three
um than um uh multiverse of madness
mainly because
i i have this weird feeling that the
rules of time travel and the rules of
the multiverse are sort of different
because i feel like the rules of time
travel apply to your specific universe
um and then like each universe has like
their own uh timelines that you can
alter
but like if you want to multiverse
travel you gotta go deeper
than that interesting if you have to
break through of the universe
you're the laws of your universe to go
to another universe where they have
different laws of time
anyway interesting i like that idea a
lot empty
i wonder though uh because mike waldron
is a showrunner for loki
i'm pretty sure they brought in mike
waldron to do the latest draft of
multiverse of madness
so it's the same writer behind both
things okay
uh and of the series we know of i think
loki might be the only one that's been
uh hit up for a second season yeah so
like it's one thing with wanda vision
and for falcon winter soldier to be kind
of self-contained a to b
stories that just kind of end where they
end but loki is something that seems
like they want to keep this going and be
like an active part of the mcu and the
way they continue to build it out
so yeah i i think we might be able to
expect it
to uh to be more um
affecting in the world than it seemed
like falcon winter soldier was
yeah and like that loki has the well the
premise of loki has the advantage of
being outside of space time
so like they can have as many seasons as
tom middleton wants theoretically
because you can just hop through time
and do whatever the hell you want um and
it's set in a different timeline as well
so it's just like
you can have as many seasons of loki as
you want and tom hiddleston's loki
is a money maker like people will sign
up for disney plus
to see tom middleton be tom middleton
and he's great at it every time
so yeah yeah they have a really great
situation
yeah i agree um now our last
wow uh
do you think loki will appear in thor
love and thunder we know matt
damon's character from ragnarok is
confirmed to be in it and he played like
the actor version of loki and the stage
play but do we think tom hiddleston loki
will get somehow resurrected or brought
in from an alternate timeline to be in
that movie
i think that he has a chance to appear
in it
i think that if he does appear in it you
probably would appear towards the end
because like it just feels to me that
this is going to be a story about
you know gods and like god's dying and
like the i feel like they're going to
explain like the the lifestyle
the life cycle of a god and so with with
gore going around and
presumably i'm assuming he's going to
kill the the the roman gods
um with you know zeus and all them wait
no they're greek gods they're not
gods or yeah uh yeah right yeah right i
keep mixing up oh yeah
i'm assuming that uh gore the god
butcher is going to kill off the the
greek gods
and so we're gonna probably see what
loki meant by
the sun will shine on us again brother
in uh avengers
infinity war um and so i think that
he might learn some lessons from the
loki tv series
that he somehow i don't know brings in
through his resurrection
i don't know it's but yeah anyway the
point is i do think that loki will
appear in thor love and thunder
in some capacity because it is a thor
movie and loki is a staple of that
series but what do you think it's
a thor movie and a crowded thor movie
you know so like
thor is gonna be in it jane foster's
coming back but also like all the uh
guardians of the galaxy are gonna be in
it yeah you know star-lord is gonna be
there it seems like groot drax
rocket you know uh nebula like they're
all gonna be part of it
plus valkyrie we assume is coming back
plus corgan meek
you know yeah that's a big movie a lot
of comedic relief it sounds like more of
an ensemble
movie and then you have like a heavy
hitter like christian bale like he's not
gonna be a small
role like he doesn't sign on for that
unless he's got a lot to do
yeah so where does loki fit into that
story i wonder
you know i'm not as sure as i was in the
ragnarok
well i mean in terms i mean you could
sort of
use the tva element to sort of tie it
into gore because like gore
has been around for a while i mean he
does have that necro sword that was
around since the beginning of time
so we could you know have loki we could
see like the beginnings of the necro
sword in loki and like
we will find find out more about it in
thor four
but um you know there is that the
beginnings of the universe that we could
find
loki visiting in his show that could um
you know eventually tie into thor 11
thunder but
i don't know exactly how loki would find
his way back into the mainstream marvel
timeline because he's pretty dead
so he would have to be some type of
resurrection right
and if loki gets resurrected any
character can get resurrected at that
point right yeah i guess you could
already say
gamora kind of set that rule for the mcu
right if she can come in from another
history so can
so can anybody uh well we'll keep an eye
on all this stuff
as we look ahead to loki coming june 9th
and another reminder that
that uh week of june as soon as loki
comes out inside marvel this show
will ship to wednesdays uh the day of
those episode releases with our
breakdowns coming out the next day
we'll give you more updates on how our
schedule's gonna adjust
you know when that happens uh but until
then mt and i are gonna be back every
friday
covering all the big marvel news over
these next few weeks whether it's loki
whether some other big stuff comes out
uh and we're very excited it's it's a
great great time to be a marvel fan
uh so follow mt at mastertainment follow
me at eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcasts
and subscribe to rockstars here on
youtube and we'll see you next time
bye-bye take it easy guys
[Music]
you